happy birthday to me I wouldn't saw
criminal today wow I really shouldn't
have done that
check out this cast criminal stars
Superman's dad two-face Deadpool Wonder
Woman and Commissioner Gordon of course
I know who all these actors are and I'm
fans of all of them which is one of the
biggest reasons I went and saw this
movie because I am fans of this cast
this movie has a weird plot is sort of
like a twist on the movie face-off with
Nicolas Cage and John Travolta this
sadistic criminal played by Kevin
Costner gets a brain transplant from
Ryan Reynolds in a way but it's not
really a brain transplant it's more of a
memory transplant the character
portrayed by Ryan Reynolds has very
important memories and they need to get
those memories so they take some guy
who's just like a nothing some guy who's
just rotting in jail and they put the
memories inside of him to hopefully
extract those memories that they
couldn't get from Ryan Reynolds because
he's dead and as you might expect the
brain of the sadistic killer as well as
the nice husband are now clashing and we
have a movie criminal is an interesting
idea and that's the best thing it has
going for it and if it was portrayed in
the way that the movie face off
portrayed that kind of idea a lot more
lighthearted more tongue-in-cheek
self-aware then this movie could have
been something really cool but it takes
itself dreadfully seriously to the point
where it's impossible to really have any
fun with this movie the performances for
the most part are fine Kevin Costner
clearly is having a great time playing
this guy although it's not that much fun
watching him because it's not so much
that ludicrous idea that's the problem
it's entirely the execution the
screenplay the dialogue the convoluted
mess of a story and direction that
doesn't really have a style of its own
all of these things clash to make a
movie that could have been a lot of fun
that is filled with mostly good
performances and turns it into something
that's just a bore and as I said the
performances are mostly really good I
like Kevin Costner I like Ryan Reynolds
in his limited screen time
my favorite part this movie was actually
gal gadot she was great this is actually
the best work I've ever seen from her
because I haven't really seen that much
from her her role in The Fast and
Furious movies was always kind of very
like went to the camera smile I Drive a
fast motorcycle type thing and as Wonder
Woman she was badass but you know there
wasn't really that much to her character
she was just badass this was actually a
character and she did a really good job
in this movie Tommy Lee Jones and Gary
Oldman both collect a paycheck here
there's nothing really that remarkable
about their characters or the
performance in fact I don't even
remember their names they're just people
who talked the best thing this movie has
going forward is its fun idea and some
good performances but the movie has no
idea how to take this story and have it
make sense and have it be cohesive and
know I don't need everything spoon-fed
to me I'm getting so tired of hearing
that oh sorry the story didn't
spoon-feed everything to you that's just
an excuse for whoops our script wasn't
that great seriously when I hear that as
a defense for poor storytelling it bugs
the living shit out of me because I love
hard to understand movies one of my
favorite movies of 2014 was enemy I mean
what the hell was that movie about and I
loved it this movie story is so messy
and so all over the place that you can't
really harness it and it has the worst
excuse for a weak-ass villain just some
guy who just wants to blow everything up
and he is laughably awful in this movie
there really isn't that much else to say
about criminal don't waste your time
with this movie it wastes a kind of fun
idea and a fantastic cast with poor
workman like execution I'm going to give
criminal adhi guys thank you so much as
always for watching and thank you so
much for the birthday well wishes on my
jungle book review you guys are awesome
thank you very much if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes